ich habe mich heute gearbeitet über die
bundeswehr eigentlich nicht über
gebunden das wäre selbst dann um den
umgang mit der bundeswehr wir sehen
nämlich heute annegret kramp karrenbauer
die verteidigungsministerin ist nach das
kennt gereist nach usbekistan dort wo
die soldaten aus afghanistan gramm mit
ihnen dann zurück nach wünsdorf nach
nieder sagt eine tolle geste klar aber
wo war annegret kramp karrenbauer im
juni als nämlich der offiziellen letzte
transporter aus afghanistan kam nach 20
jahren einsatz nach über 100.000
soldaten die da im wechsel waren nach
vielen vielen tod leider auch die wir zu
erleiden hatten da weil sie nicht da
aber auch kein außenminister aber auch
keine bundeskanzlerin sondern die
soldaten waren allein und haben sich
auch so gefühlt und die nachgeschobene
begründung damals nahm man wollte nur
dass sie da nach hause können und nicht
unterbrochen werden die wirkte nur sehr
merkwürdig die bundeswehr hat
großartiges geleistet jetzt in kabul wo
sie mehr als 5000 leute rausgeholt hat
4500 afghanen 500 deutsche sie hat
großartiges geleistet bei der flut wo
sie mit schwerem gerät reingegangen ist
sie hat großartiges geleistet auch bei
krone wo sie in altenheim unterstützt
hat und in impfzentren und die fragen
nicht nach namen life balance sondern
sie wollen deutschland dienen und ich
finde sie haben mehr respekt verdient
nicht nur wenn die kameras auf sie
gerichtet sind
ein sehr sehr wichtiges thema bilder ich
muss immer sagen dass mit dem respekt
finde ich immens wichtig für unsere
bundeswehr deswegen fand ich so toll
dass wir heute über dieses thema
sprechen weil nicht als afghanistan
zeigt ja wir brauchen eine starke
bundeswehr aber jetzt habe ich meine
frage an die männer und ich weiß man
hätte es auch als frau machen können
freiwillig wer ist denn hier in der
runde weil wir brauchen eine starke
bundeswehr nach respekt eigentlich für
die wehrpflicht dass die wieder
eingeführt wird ich bin absolut dafür
also ich halte es für ein ich glaube
nicht dass ich wieder eine und wie ich
glaube nicht dass sie wieder eingeführt
werden soll wird das geld dass jeder
einmal gedient das ist passé aber ich
war sehr dagegen dass sie abgeschafft
wird und findet es gab die möglichkeit
natürlich ersatzdienst machen oder
irgendwas beim technischen hilfsdienst
aber für die die bei der bundeswehr
waren und ich war da war das schon
eine prägende zeit das wird immer auch
lächerlich gemacht gern aber es war es
bei mir auf jeden fall wo warst du
wieder weg ich war bei den damals ließen
sie noch panzer aufklärern hat er
elegant aufklärer eleganter sich auch in
lüneburg damals ja und ich bin auch
leute reserve insofern obergefreiter ich
müsste jetzt vor dir nein nein
das ist ja auch weiß man nicht erst sich
jetzt immer gefragt hier einige tipps
die wir wollen ja im klartext also
insofern ist das ist so quasi einmal
wehrdienst gemacht zwölf monate nach ich
war matrose war bei der marine das ist
nur noch nicht ja und warum das schiff
war der mann kaputt also ich lag 1 uhr
am hafen ja als schicker uniform das
stimmt und dann bist du nach dem halben
jahr wirst du matrose wurdest du damals
war es noch ein bisschen matrose wurde
es dann gefreiter und der abschiedsgruß
war dann der obergefreite der reserve
und das war einfach quasi einmal
durchlaufen nichts besonderes aber alles
hast du denn so goldene linie bei der
beide uniform bei der ungefähren hast du
nur so zwei kleine na ja wir sind dabei
uns gegangen sind
und deswegen die frage auch die gestellt
dass nina die wehrpflicht haben oder
weil der bundesregierung sagt ganz
ehrlich sagen ich glaube das tun wird
der bundeswehr keinen gefallen gibt ja
auch keine wehrpflicht für den
polizeidienst ab ich habe ja
festgestellt was ich konnte das war
bescheiden
und ich glaube das ist auch der
bundeswehr und den anforderungen die wir
haben an die bundeswehr wird das
überhaupt nicht mehr rechnung tragen
heute also ich sags dafür irgendwelche
funkgeräten meistens auch kaputt und hab
da versucht darum zu fummeln meine
technischen fähigkeiten sind gering und
deswegen muss ich sagen da müssen profis
ran und ich würde sagen aus dem grund
keine wehrpflicht erst mal als alexander
und wer vielleicht war es sogar mehr
existiert eine eine familieninterne
wehrpflicht beschließen meine beiden
söhne gegen seine versetzung und es wäre
die tochter interessant im tochter hat
sich eher für das soziale entschieden
aber gerade weil mit dem malteser
hilfsdienst im libanon und hat dort in
einem behindertenheim gearbeitet dass
sie so ihre zeigen ihre ihre wh
vielleicht tollen beitrag zu leisten
meinen kindern steht auf jeden fall klar
wir müssen was tun für andere übrigens
auch ein glücksgeheimnis also ihm eine
glückliche zeit war bei der bei der
bundesmarine das ist etwas was uns beide
alex anschuldigung glücklich sind
abgesehen ab wir sind jederzeit offen
war jetzt aber wer hofft er auf dem
rücken eines pferdes ist die
glücklichste existenz schlechthin ist er
dann beim planen und dann kommt in der
welt aber auch ich muss sagen jaja
wird wird mir beipflichten es gibt
nichts schöneres als die nase im wind zu
haben ja und du hast und du hast du mal
0 war und du bist über tage lang und
lockig träger ist vor dir und du bist im
windschatten und das ist doch mal was
wollen sie das ist abenteuer was werden
männlich aber nicht so viele frauen aber
aber das thema war ja eigentlich bin ich
sehr sehr wichtig wir haben respekt aber
nicht nur interessiert daran wie das
mauerwerk nicht ich finde das geht ja
hoffentlich genau da hat uns vielleicht
noch als lehrer ist hier haben es noch
kein holen es ist ja auch kein
schaden das ist gibt das ich finde
schade was ich gerade merkel hier alle
hier so netten über die bundeswehr reden
schaltet irgendwo anders ein und findet
irgendwann diskussion wurde er wohl der
bundeswehr mal wertschätzung gebracht
wird ich finde wir sollten diesen
momenten vorschalten heute habe ich weil
die boni der violinist schätzen sie die
wohnungen müssen wir fest auf so was ich
einer besorgt ist braucht sowas wie ein
tag den haben ja seit tagen der tag der
bundeswehr ganz klar es gibt ein
hundetag ich habe auch mal nachgeguckt
es gibt sogar ein tag der mandarine und
40 gibt sicher auch vertagt aber
natürlich ja und ist eine nächsten monat
nächste woche gibt es den tag des
zebrastreifens es gibt auch ein tag der
unklarheit ja er ist wichtig nächste
woche ich weiß warum und machen
und das gern aber nicht nur wehrpflicht
für männer sondern auch für frauen ich
finde das ganz gut wie die das in israel
machen jeder sollte
daran teilnehmen und gewissermaßen
ausgebildet werden dadurch entsteht
anerkennung für die bundeswehr und für
diese menschen die wirklich als
berufssoldaten viel für uns leisten und
ich damals hatte leider die deutsche
staatsbürgerschaft und nicht irgendwann
zu klein ich weiter derweil das wäre
besonders gut merken hoffentlich zu
hause das wir diskutieren müssen
vielleicht darüber themen die dem einen
oder anderen stern drüber zu reden aber
vielleicht auch um den einen oder
anderen zu bekehren aber es muss man
auch nicht in jeder diskussion man kann
auch einfach sich dazu einigen auch mal
zu disziplin ich hoffe sie hatten spaß
weil wir hatten es auf jeden fall ne
runde und wir möchten jungen leute
schließen vielen dank an die bundeswehr
wir sind sehr dankbar dass wir sie haben
und wir brauchen sie jeden einzelnen tag
[Musik]